dit que tu étais beau bien
être bon dans ce genre de travail n'est pas
très beau ils nous regardent maintenant
m'embrasser après la guerre frapper l'endroit quand
la guerre sera finie peu importe où je suis
nous nous sommes retrouvés viens avec moi
Londres sois ma femme
je t'aime de tout mon coeur
commandant nos agents sont décodés
trafic ennemi il s'agit de ta femme
il n'y a pas de moyen facile de dire ce que
nous allons dire
bon être bon dans ce genre de travail n'est
pas très beau qu'est-ce que tu fais
t'habiller comme tu m'as testé est-ce
qu'ils te font confiance je suis très doué pour faire
semblant max ils nous regardent comment
m'embrasser
quelles sont les chances de
survivre 64 contre
[  Musique]
Je t'ai dit qu'ils venaient pour toi finalement
n'ai-je pas max est-ce un
test de jeu